check it out swanky site so we got this
uh from timcast.com shock poll two in
three southern republicans want to
secede from the united states and this
story is actually based off of a a
little quote tweet i had when i tweeted
at the chen kuger jenk of the young turk
says according to a new yougov poll
two-third of southern republicans want
to secede from america where have i seen
this movie before but this time it's a
confederacy of dunces led by king dunce
trump by the way when you want to betray
america that makes you by definition
un-american oh man jake euger
jake you got those southern republicans
they want to secede from the union how
dumb are they you know anybody in any
political faction that wants to must be
really really dumb oh hey let me pull up
the poll that shows 47 percent of
democrats in the west which includes
through california want to secede from
the union too hey where have i heard
this story before it's like a
confederacy of dunces led by who you
jenk listen listen
okay two-thirds is a lot 47
little bit less than half but come on
we're talking about in the west the
largest faction of people that want to
secede from the union according to the
the the poll that he cited our democrats
last i checked jank yuga is a democrat
and is within that faction that has
nearly 50 percent of their of their base
wanting to secede from the union so um
what's the saying uh you know living in
glass houses and throwing rocks people
people in glass houses shouldn't throw
hard stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah oh man
you got to love the young turks though
but check this out so here's here's the
actual data
well it is true that the southern
republicans 66 percent are in favor of
seceding from the union effectively this
is this effectively is a balkanization
where you've got the pacific region the
mountain region the heartland region
northeast and the south
you can see that in the mountain region
43 of republicans want to secede 35
percent of independence now here's the
one that really made me laugh
in the heartland which is basically the
midwest
43 percent of independence the plurality
want to secede from the union so there's
something about being in the midwest
where they're like we don't like
republicans or democrats
i get i feel that i think it might have
something to do with the fact that
chicago minneapolis very very democrat
so the people there are very unsatisfied
with democrats party politics is crap in
my opinion people that get all tribal
and they're like i'm good because i'm
part of this group like come on man give
me a message something that's actually
part of the analysis
when they're going through the data they
said it may be not that they actually
want to secede
from the u.s to form new regional unions
and again this poll is literally asking
people would you want to balkanize the
united states
it may be that they're trying to virtue
signal that's what one of the
researchers said like these people are
asked and they're like i'm a proud
democrat and i support the you know
right or i'm from the the west or
whatever
let me tell you something
it's uh
there's there's two different versions
of how many people wanted to declare
independence in the american revolution
for some reason for a while people
thought it was one-third in favor
one-third opposed and one-third
abstained but that was based on a letter
from john adams where he was actually
talking about the french revolution at
least that's the modern historical
interpretation
so the best data i could find is that
it's between 40 and 45
of the colonists wanted to declare
independence wow 15 to 20 wanted were
loyalists and the rest were like i don't
care leave me alone i we have talked
about this in the past so we'll consider
that a correction because we had bad
numbers last time i said it was like 35.
10
no no i've heard crazy numbers people
say only 3 actually fought i see maybe
that's what it was but here's here's the
other thing too so first i'll point out
we're like
the the the average right now is 35
percent of the country across all party
lines and all places 35 would be in
favor of balkanizing i mean that's
massive
and that's up right so in in the south
the number i think in february was 50
now it's 66. so we are moving
very very quickly if we get to 40 or 45
of the percent of the american people
being like we're done with this
my problem is it's this poll like we
were talking about this before the show
a little bit how many people were pulled
was it like a thousand people and three
hundred of them said i think it was two
thousand seven hundred something so
you've got like 600 people that said we
want to succeed and they're like 30 of
the country and it's like no that was
600 people but 2000 is enough to get a
representative sample 2 750. yeah well
that's more than enough you can get a
representative sample with 1000. i think
what it is is if what you said about
virtue signaling or people who are
partisan like if you didn't like biden
you're like i want to leave the country
but does that mean you actually want to
secede or does that mean you actually
want local autonomy because those are
two different things and for the midwest
point the reason why they're always torn
or swing voters is they're the reagan
democrats they're the people who align
with union politics who are against free
trade but on social issues they align
more with the republican party this is
why you know reagan won you know i think
in the second election every state but
minnesota and you could correct me if
i'm wrong and eventually like those
became the swing states because reagan
was converting those voters who didn't
like the excesses from the democratic
party in the social movement but were
like mostly like working-class union
voters and that's who we're fighting
over now it's the same set of voters
that reagan flipped then so like they're
that's why i think the independents are
like i want to get out of here because
neither party is really serving them in
their opinion you were correct i was
minnesota um dc as well but obviously
it's not a state so but it was it was
just minnesota yeah um i i i think
people are serious about balkanization
we saw there was that uh war game that
the dnc did it was heavily reported on
before the election where uh boston
globe uh reported john podesta wha
what's his position he's like the chair
of the dnc or some high-ranking position
he was uh hillary's campaign manager
right yeah he he said if trump wins the
the western states should secede from
the union cal exit if you remember that
yeah but not just california also oregon
and washington and so when you see that
47 percent of democrats there according
to a representative sample which as you
said is more than enough 27 2750
that's a lot of people that sounds like
virtue signaling that podesta would say
that people should should succeed
because anyone's private he didn't
publicly say it okay it was in a private
dnc war game that
some people who are witness to it talk
to some journalists
so podesta didn't come out and say hey
guys go do this privately he was like i
think this is what needs to happen and
then someone went to the journalist and
we're like yo this is what he's saying
not that i can trust any of these
journalists mind you for all i know john
podesta didn't say anything
but like what do you do when they lie
i've had i've had journalists
manufacture quotes from me
yeah one guy from i think it's the new
yorker where he took two different
quotes and put them together to make a
different sentence amazing or like half
a quote usually if you widen it out
10 words in either direction or 30
seconds in a clip and it changes
completely what they say then maybe
maybe you shouldn't be running with that
idea there's a clever way to get around
giving quotes to journalists when you
know they're going to try and pull some
bs and it's to add
like breaks
that are seemingly non-sequitur in your
sentence
so like
if someone were to say what's your
favorite color i would say my tim poole
favorite color because i grew up in
south side of chicago is actually and
this is because of my birthday green and
then what they'll have to do is they'll
put my dot dot dot favorite color dot
dot and it it makes it impossible so if
you're if you're trying to make sure
they can't pull things out of context
you can add things to it that forces
them to put in by doing that otherwise
they can try and break the sentence up
and it looks really weird in print when
what they usually do then is just do a
paraphrase with like he expressed to me
his favorite color was green or
something all right i mean if you set it
in audio they might put your face if
there's video over the audio and just
cut it together that the way that they
want it oh yeah yeah that's why i don't
talk down talking on the phone you know
there's phones for certain things but
anyway back to uh the vulcanization by
the
way
not gonna lead anything five percent in
his congressional run
let us never forget he was going to show
us how progressives could win in purple
districts by the way but i just i just
love how the shows that jen didn't
actually go to the website
like i i pulled up the article from
brightline watch to read the data so i
could do a segment about this and i did
it earlier on my my tim cass channel
because i'm like what does it mean that
republicans want to secede the south
wants to succeed and i pull them like oh
it's actually
missing the bigger picture i guess if
you actually add all these up and
average it out it's a decent amount of
people so 35 might actually be relative
it might be incorrect because i'm i'm
adding up the totals and then dividing
it by the regions and it doesn't
necessarily represent how many people in
each region actually want to succeed so
the heartland i mean i i think we need
to go by population density so i'm sure
the heartland doesn't have as many
people as the south the south probably
has substantially more people between
florida texas atlanta and then you look
at the pacific which is alaska
california oregon and washington
probably a lot less people
so the percentages probably don't add up
properly the way i'm describing it in
fact it could be substantially more if
we actually go by population density and
did better math right i i would tend to
think that it would be less at least the
serious ones are definitely less i would
like to see
um like you ever seen like sam harris
break down the spheres of influence of
radicalization like that version of this
where it's like these people want to
leave but do they really just want local
autonomy
what's the difference i don't understand
what you mean well it's like uh the
states rights movements under under
obama like they would say that texas
should secede and break you know be its
own state or break up into five states
as it says in their constitution but in
reality they just wanted like the
governor to invoke more 10th amendment
stuff against obama and challenge what
he was doing which is similar to what
happened in california so how do you
know that's actually what they wanted
though well because i don't think when
push comes to shove these people would
actually vote in like a secessionist
party in their state i think they would
i think i think you often see that
regular people
vote for the extreme version of of these
things because of like especially right
now as the rhetoric is ramping up
i mean do they though because they voted
in biden in the primary and like he was
distinctly not extreme like in the
primary at least compared to who he's
talking to bernie who but what what did
the people say they wanted
well in polls they would say that like
in the top line polls that's why i don't
trust polling they would say that they
would want bernie sanders positions in
the top line police but when you go into
the details you realize that they think
medicare for all is obamacare with the
public option which is actually biden's
position which is why when the
progressives were like we won on every
issue well so they voted for what they
wanted yeah
right so if an individual says they want
to secede they probably vote for it no
but that's the top line like that that
would be your i want medicare for all
but then when you ask them what what do
you think this actually means okay like
and you break it down like you're going
to get a wait you're going to get people
who just want states rights or autonomy
or maybe like an american federation
where they break up
some people want that but not right they
don't know what their what they want if
they really like what is a secession a
you attempt by military force to like
the american federal government will
come to fight you and kill people and
burn cities
to stop that state from seceding i don't
think they want that it's it's like if
you ever got into a fight with a
girlfriend and she's like i want to
break up with you
and then you're like okay okay let's
talk about this and then you talk about
and you realize she just wants you to
stop being a jerk like you know it comes
down from that top-line aggressive thing
it is it is because if they start saying
that then you're like you know i'm gonna
start taking you your word you gotta
take them at their work oh yeah yeah i
don't i don't i don't i don't play games
like that if someone came up to me and
they were like
you know if someone came up to me and
said i'm going to quit because i'm
unhappy
it's great working with you what would
secession look like then if we could def
lay it out for people clearly like well
so so uh i think
civil war won't work in this regard
we're talking about five region
balkanization right right so i will say
first and foremost joe biden keeps
talking about this being the greatest
threat since the civil war and blah blah
blah he's using the power of the federal
government to go after trump's
supporters and people they deem to be
extreme they're potentially i guess it's
now public they're compiling lists of
these people you know they're going to
be tracking the jackpot reported it and
there's some statements about it so what
would it look like well
there's there's
there is a lot of power in the federal
government but that power is derived
from the states and i don't mean that
figuratively like the states chose to
create the federal government no like
the people who are in the federal
government are sent there are voted in
the the the the capitol police the
national guard the the power the federal
government has all across the country
from people who serve in the military
and the armed forces come from states so
what would happen if
somebody lives in say you know oregon
and they're as far left as they come and
they work in some kind of law
enforcement capacity and then
someone in the federal government says
something we want to do x we we need
your assistance but if if the country is
balkanizing they might say no i care i
care more about my state than i care
about going to dc to do whatever you
want or if balkanization is happening
and then someone in oregon is told like
we're going to be deploying you to texas
they're going to be like i got to stay
and defend oregon yeah so it's it's that
is a question of if we balkanize but
here's what i think is possible
if this sentiment
is this widespread 47 percent in the
west makes sense to me 33 percent of
independence and 66 percent of
republicans and 50 percent of
independents in the south that's crazy
and these are very heavily republic uh
uh right
republican states
what i think actually could happen is
loss of confidence
in which case this is what i talked
about several times as to how i think a
civil war could actually happen not that
a bunch of states get together and say
we hereby declare good sir and start
gaining someone in congress but actually
what happens is a small town in oklahoma
puts up a roadblock and says not welcome
and then start saying we're not going to
abide by these lockdowns or whatever joe
biden is saying and then the feds have
to come in and the people in oklahoma
say we are not letting you in our town
you have no you have you you have no
purchase here good sir look
look at what what happens in like ohio
where they i think they arrested an atf
agent right those are exactly the kinds
of things that start happening now you
have second amendment sanctuaries
popping up and i think two-thirds of the
counties the united states
that is a is a break of confidence at a
at a growing scale so biden's freaking
out it's the greatest threat what the
republicans are doing uh because he
probably sees the federal government's
power is actually starting to dwindle
ohio recently some sheriff said we're no
longer going to be taking illegal
immigrants from ice why because they
send them here they tell us to hold them
and let them go into our towns no dice
not gonna happen
the plans that they had not working
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you